the Riemann zeta-function
this is one of those objects in modern
math that a lot of you might have heard
of but which can be really difficult to
understand
don't worry I'll explain that animation
that you just saw in a few minutes a lot
of people know about this function
because there's a 1 million dollar prize
out for anyone who can figure out when
it equals 0 an open problem known as the
Riemann hypothesis some of you may have
heard of it in the context of the
divergence some 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4
on and on up to infinity you see there's
a sense in which the sum equals negative
112 which seems nonsensical if not
obviously wrong but a common way to
define what this equation is actually
saying uses the Riemann zeta function
but as any casual math enthusiast who's
started to read into this knows its
definition references this one idea
called analytic continuation which has
to do with complex valued functions and
this idea can be frustratingly opaque
and unintuitive
so what I'd like to do here is just show
you all what this zeta function actually
looks like and to explain what this idea
of analytic continuation is in a visual
and more intuitive way I'm assuming that
you know about complex numbers and that
you're comfortable working with them and
I'm tempted to say that you should know
calculus since analytic continuation is
all about derivatives but for the way
I'm planning to present things I think
you might actually be fine without that
so to jump right into it let's just
define what this zeta function is for a
given input where we commonly use the
variable s the function is 1 over 1 to
the S which is always 1 plus 1 over 2 to
the S plus 1 over 3 to the s plus 1 over
4 to the S on and on and on
summing up over all natural numbers
so for example let's say you plug in a
value like s equals 2 you'd get 1 plus 1
over 4 plus 1 over 9 plus 1/16 and as
you keep adding more and more
reciprocals of squares this just so
happens to approach PI squared over 6
which is around 1.645 there's a very
beautiful reason for why pi shows up
here and I might do a video on it at a
later date but that's just the tip of
the iceberg for why this function is
beautiful you could do the same thing
for other inputs s like 3 or 4 and
sometimes you get other interesting
values and so far everything feels
pretty reasonable you're adding up
smaller and smaller amounts and these
sums approach some number great no
craziness here yet if you were to read
about it you might see some people say
that Zeta of negative 1 equals negative
112 but looking at this infinite sum
that doesn't make any sense when you
raise each term to the negative 1
flipping each fraction you get 1 plus 2
Plus 3 plus 4 on a non overall natural
numbers and obviously that doesn't
approach anything certainly not negative
112 right and as any mercenary looking
into the Riemann hypothesis knows this
function is said to have trivial zeros
at negative even numbers so for example
that would mean that Zeta of negative 2
equals 0 but when you plug in negative 2
it gives you 1 plus 4 plus 9 plus 16 on
and on which again obviously doesn't
approach anything much less 0 right well
we'll get to negative values in a few
minutes but for right now let's just say
the only thing that seems reasonable
this function only makes sense when s is
greater than 1 which is when this sum
converges so far it's simply not defined
for other values now with that said
bernhard riemann was somewhat of a
father to complex analysis which is the
study of functions that have complex
numbers as inputs and outputs so rather
than just thinking about how this sum
takes a number s on the real number line
to another number on the real number
line
his main focus was on understanding what
happens when you plug in a complex value
for s so for example maybe instead of
plugging in two you would plug in two
plus I now if you've never seen the idea
of raising a number to the power of a
complex value it can feel kind of
strange at first because it no longer
has anything to do with repeated
multiplication but mathematicians found
that there is a very nice and very
natural way to extend the definition of
exponents beyond their familiar
terra-tory of real numbers and into the
realm of complex values it's not super
crucial to understand complex exponents
for where I'm going with this video but
I think it'll still be nice if we just
summarize the gist of it here the basic
idea is that when you write something
like 1/2 to the power of a complex
number you split it up as 1/2 to the
real part times 1/2 to the pure
imaginary part we're good on 1/2 to the
real part there's no issues there but
what about raising something to a pure
imaginary number well the result is
going to be some complex number on the
unit circle in the complex plane as you
let that pure imaginary input walk up
and down the imaginary line the
resulting output walks around that unit
circle
for a base like one-half the output
walks around the unit circle somewhat
slowly but for a base that's farther
away from one like 1/9 then as you let
this input walk up and down the
imaginary axis the corresponding output
is going to walk around the unit circle
more quickly if you've never seen this
and you're wondering why on earth this
happens I've left a few links to good
resources in the description for here
I'm just going to move forward with the
what without the why the main takeaway
is that when you raise something like
1/2 to the power of 2 plus I which is
1/2 squared times 1/2 to the I that 1/2
to the I part is going to be on the unit
circle meaning it has an absolute value
of 1 so when you multiply it it doesn't
change the size of the number it just
takes that 1/4 and rotates it somewhat
so if you were to plug in 2 plus I to
the zeta function one way to think about
what it does is to start off with all of
the terms raised to the power of 2 which
you can think of as piecing together
lines whose lengths are the reciprocals
of squares of numbers which like I said
before converges to PI squared over 6
then when you change that input from 2
up to 2 plus I each of these lines gets
rotated by some amount but importantly
the lengths of those lines won't change
so the sum still converges it just does
so in a spiral to some specific point on
the complex plane here let me show what
it looks like when I vary the input S
represented with this yellow dot on the
complex plane where this spiral sum is
always going to be showing the
converging value for Zeta of s
[Music]
you
what this means is that Zeta of s
defined as this infinite sum is a
perfectly reasonable complex function as
long as the real part of the input is
greater than 1 meaning the input s sits
somewhere on this right half of the
complex plane again this is because it's
the real part of s that determines the
size of each number while the imaginary
part just dictates some rotation so now
what I want to do is visualize this
function it takes in inputs on the right
half of the complex plane and spits out
outputs somewhere else in the complex
plane a super nice way to understand
complex functions is to visualize them
as transformations meaning you look at
every possible input to the function and
just let it move over to the
corresponding output for example let's
take a moment and try to visualize
something a little bit easier than the
zeta function say F of s is equal to s
squared when you plug in s equals 2 you
get 4 so we'll end up moving that point
at 2 over 2 the point at 4 when you plug
in negative 1 you get 1 so the point
over here at negative 1 is going to end
up moving over to the point at 1 when
you plug in I by definition its square
is negative 1 so it's going to move over
here to negative 1
now I'm gonna add on a more colorful
grid and this is just because things are
about to start moving and it's kind of
nice to have something to distinguish
grid lines during that movement from
here I'll tell the computer to move
every single point on this grid over to
its corresponding output under the
function f of s equals s squared here's
what it looks like
that can be a lot to take in so I'll go
ahead and play it again and this time
focus on one of the marked points and
notice how it moves over to the point
corresponding to its square it can be a
little complicated to see all of the
points moving all at once but the reward
is that this gives us a very rich
picture for what the complex function is
actually doing and it all happens in
just two dimensions so back to the zeta
function we have this infinite sum which
is a function of some complex number s
and we feel good and happy about
plugging in values of s whose real part
is greater than 1 and getting some
meaningful output via the converging
spiral song so to visualize this
function I'm going to take the portion
of the grid sitting on the right side of
the complex plane here where the real
part of numbers is greater than 1 and
I'm going to tell the computer to move
each point of this grid to the
appropriate output it actually helps if
I add a few more grid lines around the
number one since that region gets
stretched out by quite a bit all right
so first of all let's all just
appreciate how beautiful that is I mean
damn that doesn't make you want to learn
more about complex functions you have no
heart but also this transformed grid is
just begging to be extended a little bit
for example
let's highlight these lines here which
represent all of the complex numbers
with imaginary part I or negative I
after the transformation these lines
make such lovely arcs before they just
abruptly stop don't you want to just you
know continue those arcs in fact you can
imagine how some altered version of the
function with the definition that
extends into this left half of the plane
might be able to complete this picture
with something that's quite pretty well
this is exactly what mathematicians
working with complex functions do they
continue the function beyond the
original domain where was
find now as soon as we branch over into
inputs where the real part is less than
one this infinite sum that we originally
use to define the function doesn't make
sense anymore
you'll get nonsense like adding one plus
two plus three plus four on and on up to
infinity but just looking at this
transformed version of the right half of
the plane where the sum does make sense
it's just begging us to extend the set
of points that we're considering as
inputs even if that means defining the
extended function in some way that
doesn't necessarily use that sum of
course that leaves us with the question
how would you define that function on
the rest of the plane you might think
that you could extend it any number of
ways
maybe you define an extension that makes
it so the point at say s equals negative
1 moves over to negative 1/12
but maybe you squiggle on some extension
that makes it land on any other value I
mean as soon as you open yourself up to
the idea of defining the function
differently for values outside that
domain of convergence that is not based
on this infinite sum the world is your
oyster and you can have any number of
extensions right well not exactly I mean
yes you can give any child a marker and
have them extend these lines any which
way but if you add on the restriction
that this new extended function has to
have a derivative everywhere it walks us
into one and only one possible extension
I know I know I said that you wouldn't
need to know about derivatives for this
video and even if you do know calculus
maybe you have yet to learn how to
interpret derivatives for complex
functions but luckily for us there is a
very nice geometric intuition that you
can keep in mind for when I say a phrase
like has a derivative everywhere here to
show you what I mean let's look back at
that F of s equals s squared example
again we think of this function as a
transformation moving every point s of
the complex plane over to the point s
squared for those of you who know
calculus you know that you can take the
derivative of this function at any given
input but there's an interesting
property of that transformation that
turns out to be related and almost
equivalent to that fact if you look at
any two lines in the input space that
intersect at some angle and consider
what they turn into after the
transformation they will still intersect
each other at that same angle the lines
might get curved and that's ok but the
important part is that the angle at
which they intersect remains unchanged
and this is true for any pair of lines
that you choose so when I say a function
has a derivative everywhere I want you
to think about this angle preserving
property that anytime two lines
intersect the angle between them remains
unchanged after the transformation at a
glance this is easiest to appreciate by
noticing how all of the curves that the
gridlines turn into still intersect each
other at right angles complex functions
that have a derivative everywhere are
called analytic so you can think of this
term analytic as meaning angle
preserving admittedly I'm lying to you a
little here but only a little bit a
slight caveat for those of you who want
the full details is that at inputs where
the derivative of a function is zero
instead of angle being preserved they
get multiplied by some integer but those
points are by far the minority and for
almost all inputs to an analytic
function angles are preserved so if when
I say analytic you think angle
preserving I think that's a fine
intuition to have
[Music]
now if you think about it for a moment
and this is a point that I really want
you to appreciate this is a very
restrictive property the angle between
any pair of intersecting lines has to
remain unchanged and yet pretty much any
function out there that has a name turns
out to be analytic the field of complex
analysis which Riemann helped to
establish in its modern form is almost
entirely about leveraging the properties
of analytic functions to understand
results in patterns and other fields of
math and science the zeta function
defined by this infinite sum on the
right half of the plane is an analytic
function notice how all of these curves
that the gridlines turn into still
intersect each other at right angles so
the surprising fact about complex
functions is that if you want to extend
an analytic function beyond the domain
where it was originally defined for
example extending this zeta function
into the left half of the plane then if
you require that the new extended
function still be analytic that is that
it still preserves angles everywhere it
forces you into only one possible
extension if one exists at all it's kind
of like an infinite continuous jigsaw
puzzle where this requirement of
preserving angles walks you into one and
only one choice for how to extend it
this process of extending an analytic
function in the only way possible that
still analytic is called as you may have
guessed analytic continuation so that's
how the full Riemann zeta function is
defined for values of s on the right
half of the plane where the real part is
greater than one just plug them into
this sum and see where it converges and
that convergence might look like some
kind of spiral since freezing each of
these terms to a complex power has the
effect of rotating each one then for the
rest of the plane we know that there
exists one and only one way to extend
this definition so that the function
will still be analytic that is so that
it still preserves angles at every
single point so we just say that by
definition the zeta function on the left
half of the plane is
whatever that extension happens to be
and that's a valid definition because
there's only one possible analytic
continuation notice that's a very
implicit definition
it just says use the solution of this
jigsaw puzzle which through more
abstract derivation we know must exist
but it doesn't specify exactly how to
solve it
mathematicians have a pretty good grasp
on what this extension looks like but
some important parts of it remain a
mystery
a million-dollar mystery in fact let's
actually take a moment and talk about
the Riemann hypothesis the million
dollar problem the places where this
function equals zero turned out to be
quite important that is which points get
mapped on to the origin after the
transformation one thing we know about
this extension is that the negative even
numbers get mapped to zero these are
commonly called the trivial zeros the
naming here stems from a long-standing
tradition of mathematicians to call
things trivial when they understand it
quite well even when it's a fact that is
not at all obvious from the outset we
also know that the rest of the points
that get mapped to zero sits somewhere
in this vertical strip called the
critical strip and the specific
placement of those non-trivial zeros
encodes a surprising information about
prime numbers it's actually pretty
interesting why this function carries so
much information about primes and I
definitely think I'll make a video about
that later on but right now things are
long enough so I'll leave it unexplained
riemann hypothesized that all of these
non-trivial zeros sit right in the
middle of the strip on the line of
numbers s whose real part is 1/2 this is
called the critical line if that's true
it gives us a remarkably tight grasp on
the pattern of prime numbers as well as
many other patterns in math that stem
from this now so far when I've shown
what the zeta function looks like I've
only shown what it does to the portion
of the grid on the screen and that kind
of under cells its complexity so if I
were to highlight this critical line and
apply the transformation it might not
seem to cross the origin at all however
here's what the transformed version of
more
more of that line looks like notice how
it's passing through the number zero
many many times if you can prove that
all of the non-trivial zeros sit
somewhere on this line the clay math
Institute gives you 1 million dollars
and you'd also be proving hundreds if
not thousands of modern math results
that have already been shown contingent
on this hypothesis being true
another thing we know about this
extended function is that it Maps the
point negative one over two negative one
twelve and if you plug this into the
original sum it looks like we're saying
one plus two plus three plus four on and
on up to infinity equals negative 1/12
now they might seem disingenuous to
still call this a sum since the
definition of the zeta function on the
left half of the plane is not defined
directly from this sum instead it comes
from analytically continuing the sum
beyond the domain where it converges
that is solving the jigsaw puzzle that
began on the right half of the plane
that said you have to admit that the
uniqueness of this analytic continuation
the fact that the jigsaw puzzle has only
one solution is very suggestive of some
intrinsic connection between these
extended values and the original sum
you
[Music]